welcome to episode 6 of the stronger by
science podcast there have been
headlines all over the place saying that
25 cups of coffee a day is totally fine
for heart health we take a close look at
that study and figure out what it really
showed Gregg also reviews a recent
caffeine study that sought to determine
if men and women experienced the same
performance benefits from caffeine
supplementation we've also got a great
interview with multiple-time IPF world
champion Natalie Hansen we talked about
a variety of topics including her most
recent world championship
some differences between raw and
equipped powerlifting and also some
challenges that women face in strength
sports in general so thank you for
joining us and we hope you enjoy the
episode welcome back to the stronger by
science podcast this is your host Eric
Trexler I'm joined by my temporary guest
host Greg knuckles Greg how you doing
I'm doing well thank you for having me
back on of course yeah
I'd say any time but I don't want to
leave it totally open but that's a good
happy back we just want to start by
saying we want to thank everyone for
listening and we know that a lot of
people are listening because you know
Greg and I are active on the Internet we
see the social media and it appears that
there are now I guess you'd call them
some copycat podcast popping up I feel
like that's an accurate way to describe
them yeah I mean we're a few episodes in
and all of a sudden you can't throw a
rock without hitting a fitness podcast
and I'd like to say I don't know where
that came from but I definitely do yeah
I mean just so everyone is still aware
we were the first and at one time only
fitness podcast on the Internet
and they've they've just been
proliferating like rabbits in in recent
weeks so I'm not saying it's all because
of us but I'm also not not saying that
and I think the thing that adds insult
to injury is that now all of a sudden I
wake up check my email and it's people
have the gall to ask me to be a guest on
a fitness podcast are you kidding me
like literally I'm going to steal food
off your table by the way why don't you
come over for dinner yeah it's
just the sheer level of disrespect is is
mind-boggling
but anyway it's it's fine the most
sincere form of flattery is imitation so
at the very least we can take it as a
compliment and we can definitely rest
assured that nobody's gonna match our
content you can try to steal the format
but there's there's no way you're gonna
keep up with the the hard-hitting
content that we bring every week know
for sure where else are you going to
hear about you know the effects of
research that applies outside of the
context of Hinduism or learning about
doing kinesiology with crystals exactly
I feel like we're the only people
bringing that level of depth and rigor
to the subject exactly now we've got a
fan favorite segment called feats of
strength that no one has copied that yet
which is good so Greg what are the feats
of strength that you found this week
yeah so there's there's some wild stuff
going down
so recently larry wheels hit a gym PR on
the bench at 675 that's three hundred
and six kilos which one is a huge
improvement over his current meat PR
which is 610 which is two hundred and
seventy seven kilos and it's also
noteworthy because the the list of men
who have benched 675 in a meet currently
sits at 10 so that's a that's of like
the seven played bench club is a
incredibly exclusive club still and he's
got he's making so much progress on
everything I remember when he like
exploded onto the scene a couple years
ago and everyone was like who is this
dude he's crazy strong and also like
hella jacked and like I personally kind
of thought it may have been a flash in
the pan just because like dude's not
built like a typical power lifter and by
that I mean like he competes it at 275
and 308 and most guys in that weight
class just
they're just big like huge joints
generally kind of stubby like they look
like they're robustly built to lift a
tremendous amount of weight and like I
mean wheels is obviously a big dude but
just his his frame doesn't look as big
as those other dudes so I I was kind of
nervous that he may not have the
longevity to like keep pushing it before
injury started accumulating but not like
he still seems to be killing it getting
stronger at a at a crazy pace so yeah
recent recent gym PR on the bench at 675
so pretty wild also on the bench press
julius Maddux recently benched 710 which
is 322 kilos so julius Maddux I believe
has already gone over 700 in competition
before so like dude is a bona fide
monster on the bench press I feel like
he doesn't get as much attention as he
probably deserves for being a bencher of
that epsilon when people think like you
know huge benchers most of most of the
time the first name that's gonna come to
mind is either gonna be Erik's photo or
Kirill Saratov and in with with good
reason I mean those are the two most
recent world record holders but I mean
youyou should you should just google
this lift cuz like again it's another
gym lift but it looks incredibly easy
like it looked like he could have
tripled it yeah I was gonna say you
showed it to me and I was I was at first
surprised that he racked it after one
like it was so smooth I expected the
second one to come
so I mean be on the lookout cuz I mean
Sarah jeff has in PR in several years
like dude still young and huge like he
very well could be just saving up for a
big number that he's gonna come out of
nowhere and surprise everyone with but I
would not be stunned if Julius Maddox is
sitting with the bench record at the end
of this year
that's a hot cake you don't see that
another podcast that's a hot day true um
let's see few crazy deadlifts have
happened recently so Jamal browner
recently pulled 875 beltless a lot of
people also don't know who Jamal browner
is because again he's he's one of those
guys who is incredibly strong but isn't
like a world record holder in his weight
class yet and powerlifting like many
other sports like the folks people like
there's a huge drop-off in name
recognition from like best in the world
to like second or third best but Jamal
Browner's is looking crazy recently the
875 he pulled was like a legitimate
speed rep and maybe like a month ago he
pulled nine hundred for five which is
outrageous thing about those lifts is he
did them with straps his current meet PR
I believe is 865 which is 392 kilos so
like I mean that's still obviously
incredibly impressive it makes me wonder
if he may have grip issues if he doesn't
like maybe he has just gotten like crazy
strong recently and we're about to see
like a thousand pound pull out of him
which would be outrageous but yeah dudes
looking crazy strong also on the
beltless deadlift front Christoph
we're Vicki recently pulled 919 at 2:10
beltless which is 417 and 97 kilos so I
I'm not going to speculate too much but
we're Vicki is like a multi-time IPF
world champion and I believe he recently
retired from the IPF so do with that
information what you will but it's
looking like he may be about to take the
URI Belkin trajectory where like URI was
a top IPF dude I believe he got popped
not for steroids but for masking agents
if memory serves but after that he
stepped away from the IPF
the sauce in earnest and is now like
virtually untouchable in like raw
untested powerlifting it seems like we
are Bicky potentially maybe taking a
similar path but like he competes at he
competed it at 105 or 231 in the IPF and
it's looking like he's probably gonna be
220 or 100 kilo lifter if he competes
untested and currently Yuri Belkin is
like the god of the total in that weight
class and Kahler woolum it has the
deadlift record but belkin's pulled 9:26
and woolum has pulled 950 in that weight
class and it kind of looked like a
two-man race for that deadlift record
but man if so if my speculation is
correct that we're Viki previously was
either like drug-free or like yeah
whatever like maybe on low doses and
beating tests but like now is is maybe
going to you know hop on the sauce and
do it right I feel like that sounds a
little too encouraging but I'm gonna say
yeah and there's a lot of children
listening I would imagine so like as a
fan of powerlifting like I I like seeing
people hit big numbers and I really like
watching the drug-free guys but I think
untested lifting is just more
entertaining to me guys the lifts are
bigger so our lawyer right now kind of
waving me down so let me add a couple
things the drug speculation is
hypothetical in nature okay and
certainly not a recommendation anyone
any impressionable people listening at
home and just just say you're aware no
one we discuss on this podcast even if
we use their actual name and talked
about things that they actually did are
meant to comport one-to-one with real
humans in real life
correct so and everyone is a fictional
character it's like a South Park
scenario
hopefully our lawyer is good with that
anyway seems a lot more calm
anyway all of which is to say we're
picky is looking strong as hell very
well could be fixing to get considerably
stronger in the near future already a
world-class deadlift her and I'm just
excited to see where the deadlift record
in the 100 kilo class will be in the
next few years that that of all the
feats of strength that number for some
reason jumped off the page at me the
most
9:19 at 2:10 you know it did this it did
for me as well and I think the reason
why is when I got into powerlifting back
in like 2005 or whenever it was Edie
cone still had like all of the deadlift
records I think someone else may have
had 165 but I know for sure he had the
deadlift records at 181 198 220 242 and
275 and potentially 308 I think he may
have missed weight at 275 one time but
but I'm positive when I got into the
sport he had all of the records from 181
to 275 like I'm positive of that and and
the one that jumped off the page the
most was his 903 at 220 and the reason
for that is like at the time I think
maybe only four or five people had ever
dead lifted 900 and all of them were
super heavyweights like Doyle Kennedy
had Andy Bolton had Benedict Magnuson
had and then I think a little bit after
that time was when Constantine
Konstantinov was really started coming
into his own and he was like a 275 308
but like just the fact that you know you
had a very small handful of super
heavies that had pulled 900 and then
like a dude rip in it at 220 like I mean
Cohn was a monster but I think that to
me was his most impressive lift so like
that was that was the number that people
would talk about back then and say like
no one's ever going to take this record
and now the fact that both Belkin and
woolum have
broken that in a meet and we're Becky is
pulling more than that in training but
like beltless and looks very much
capable of hitting that in to meet it's
it's just wild man let's see last two
feats of strength from IPF worlds which
when you're listening to this will be
long gone but when we're recording this
is currently ongoing to me at least the
the so at the time of recording the only
lifting that's been done has been the
lightweight women so far and Megan's
Scanlan squatted 178th at 57 kilos so
that's $3 Eckerd which I feel like I'm
dating myself but when I got into the
sport a squat like that in that weight
class was would have just been
completely unheard of like just
something no one would have even
conceptualized and similarly Heather
Connor dead lifted 176 at 47 which is
388 at 103 also crazy number I remember
I remember it wasn't that long ago that
like even if you kind of had like
progressive ideas about women and and
strength sports you would still kind of
see like the women's records and be like
yeah like they're strong for women but
like it's it's seriously getting to the
point where you can't look at those
numbers and just say like that's [ __ ]
strong no matter who does it if you're
seeing someone in the in the low 100s
squatting and or dead lifting close to
400 pounds like that's wild like that's
a that's a strong person I mean I I
started my strength coaching career
working with high school wrestlers I've
seen young men in their athletic prime
who weigh less than 125 squat and they
weren't squatting that no I can tell you
that no no no so yeah like IPF worlds is
currently ongoing I'm sure there's going
to be a lot more just crazy [ __ ] that
happens over the next week of
competition but
in in terms of the early going like
those are the two numbers that really
jumped off the score sheet to me it is
like Jesus Christ that's crazy
so we've got a segment on the show
called research reviews and we've got a
couple this week I am going to lead us
off today now I love coffee Greg you
love coffee yes sir we're all coffee
lovers so anytime there's a study that
hits the hits the press about coffee it
gets a lot of attention for some reason
Fitness people and coffee are just a
match made in heaven because it tastes
good and there's no calories and it get
you all hyped up on caffeine what's not
to like now there was a paper this past
week that was really doing the rounds on
social media and the headline
essentially suggested that drinking up
to 25 cups of coffee per day did not
have adverse health effects when it came
to cardiovascular health very cool and
very legal very cool very legal now if
you've been in the game a while you know
that when you see that kind of lay press
headline of the article the only thing
you can be pretty certain of is that the
article didn't show whatever the title
says in that lay press article that
that's the only thing that you know for
certain at the outset so you very
cautiously click on it and you figure
out essentially what's the damage here
how far away from the original have we
gotten and the reason I'm bringing this
up in this week's podcast is because we
got pretty far from the actual heart of
that paper it was it was an abstract
that we're talking about here not a full
length research paper but it's called
effect of coffee consumption on arterial
stiffness from UK bio Bank imaging study
and so the idea is we've got data on a
huge group of people thousands of people
and what the researchers wanted to
figure out was how did their habitual
coffee consumption affect their arterial
stiffness so it looks like they started
out with a pool of almost 18,000
participants they had
good usable data for the final analysis
for about eighty four hundred
participants so most exercise science
studies we'd be pretty stoked if we had
forty this study had eighty four hundred
so we're venturing into the realm of
your kind of typical epidemiology type
study where we have thousands and
thousands of people which means that the
methods are often different and that
includes the statistics so the most kind
of obvious glaring thing to address
right off the bat a lot of the articles
that hit the lay press and that got
shared around social media they just
kind of understandably took a bit of a
linguistic shortcut and would say
something like 25 cups of coffee a day
no effect on heart health now I
understand why you know a title for a
lay press article can't be 25 words it's
not going to be like a small paragraph
like you see with certain research
papers but it's really important to keep
in mind that this particular study which
again is an abstract they were only
looking at arterial stiffness two
separate measurements of arterial
stiffness both of which have been shown
to be predictors of cardiovascular
events so it's not that it's wrong to
say that this study was about heart
health but a lot of a lot of the
headlines made it seem as if it was a
more comprehensive battery of tests
looking at heart health so it would have
been a lot better if the article said up
to 25 cups of coffee a day doesn't
adversely affect arterial stiffness yeah
in this population so that's kind of the
first big thing is that this was not a
complete you know caffeine is off the
hook when it comes to all sorts of
cardiovascular events we're doing
arterial stiffness is correlated with
heart health but it's not it's certainly
not the only factor in play exactly so
that's kind of the big one right off the
bat that really doesn't require a lot
more explanation the next thing that
came up in a lot of the discussions
about this abstract were who the hell is
drinking 25 cups of coffee a day
because that's a lot it is a lot and I
sit on my ass all day in my home with
unlimited access to coffee and I love
coffee and eight a day would be a huge
stretch and usually if I get to eight I
feel pretty bad yeah I mean we were we
were very recently in a research
environment as grad students surrounded
by people who were who were mostly
coffee addicts cuz that's that's kind of
an addiction you have to develop to
survive grad school and I would I would
say we weren't we weren't the two
biggest caffeine addicts in the program
but we were we were probably in the
upper quartile but even even the like
most hardcore coffee addicts in that
setting which i think is a setting that
kind of self selects for people who
drink a [ __ ] ton of coffee maybe maybe
eight to ten cups a day mmm was was the
highest that anyone I can think of may
have been sustaining the question again
who in the hell is drinking twenty five
cups of coffee a day the answer is
probably almost no one what did what
this does is it's a very good example of
something that is certainly not unique
to this study it happens all the time
and statistics and that is taking a
continuous variable and making it a
grouped variable okay so when you take a
look at the abstract itself what you see
is they took these two arterial
stiffness measurements and these are
both continuous measurements they also
figured out how much coffee these
participants were drinking on a regular
basis but what they did was instead of
leaving it as a number of you know five
cups a day or seven cups a day or one
cup a day they form three groups so you
either drank one or less cups a day
between one and three cups a day or
greater than three cups a day
and so they basically made those groups
and what they did was they said we need
to have some kind of a limit here so if
hypothetically you drank more than 25
cups a day you would be excluded this is
just an abstract which means there's not
a tremendous amount of detail and that's
not their fault I just didn't have space
for it I don't know how or why they came
to that 25 cup of day limit I mean it
wouldn't surprise me if that was just
the highest number in their sample it's
very possible they also might have
suspected if the input was above 25 that
might have been their number a which
they no longer believed it was a real
number yeah and so sometimes in in
survey data like if someone meant to put
in like 4.5 like exact sometimes four
sometimes five and they just
accidentally input it as 45 it's like no
way in hell someone's drinking forty
five cups of coffee a day exactly and
you could even imagine scenarios anytime
you do survey based research you have to
go in and figure out did people actually
give me a legitimate answer on this so I
also want to be shocked if potentially
someone were to list in ounces
how much coffee they had a day oh we ran
into that problem at stronger by science
one time we have a a still ongoing
series on some like a prospective injury
study that we did Andrew Patton was the
guy heading that up and the the reason
it's been a while since one of those
articles was published is a hundred
percent my fault but that Siri should
continue soon but yeah we we definitely
ran into that problem as well because we
wanted everything reported in kilos if
memory serves and a few people just very
obviously gave us numbers and pounds
right so you know some guy who reports
that they weigh a hundred and sixty
kilos and they're squatting four hundred
and fifty kilos it's like no like
there's a list of maybe four people in
the world that those numbers could apply
to and I guarantee you they weren't
in our little study yeah so for
something like that like you can go back
and clean the data and look to see like
okay who obviously input pounds we can
just fix that for them and then yeah
there are some numbers that are just
kind of fishy and ambiguous that did you
kind of just have to throw out and not
really trust yeah and if this were a
full paper rather than an abstract you
could kind of look and see how were the
questions worded and what's the
likelihood someone might have
misinterpreted that things like that but
for now we're kind of left to the
abstract which is a very very brief
summary of what what went down
so yeah they said if you have more than
25 cups a day we're not going to use
your data now this grouping happens
often in research and it's extremely
common in epidemiology but it happens in
other applications as well and there are
some pros to doing this type of grouping
taking a continuous variable and kind of
artificially placing people into groups
but it's not done without a cost and a
good example of that is like
hypothetically you do a little bench
press competition with six people and
you you could make it a very simple
dichotomous variable say did you
complete a rep or not yes or no so it's
kind of the most basic categorical level
of data or a little level of measurement
now you could go a step further and say
well the top three out of these six
people we're going to say that they
placed so did you place or not and so
that's a little bit more informative we
could take it a step further and do a
rank order and say so-and-so got first
they got second they got third etc so
that's more data still but I mean the
most data you could possibly have would
be to just leave it raw so I know the
the exact benchpress for every person I
know you know this person wasn't just
better than the other but they were 20
pounds better than the other so when you
whenever you kind of revert to more
simple groupings or rank order
you are losing some amount of
descriptive power when I'm not just that
you're also losing statistical power
correct yeah and so that's why you know
a lot of times when you see
nonparametric statistics applied in
research you don't see a ton of it in
exercise science but whenever you do see
it most nonparametric procedures are
quite similar to normal stats but what
they do is convert everything to a rank
order and the reason they do that is
because the data it's generally done
because the data don't conform to a
normal distribution so you violate a lot
of the normal statistical assumptions
that you would lean on so yeah you
sacrifice some of the explanatory power
and the statistical power and in the
case of this study I think there are two
really prevalent things to keep in mind
one of those things would be whenever
you do grouping like this necessarily
this grouping would suggest that the
difference between three and four cups
of coffee a day is a substantially
bigger difference than the difference
between four and twenty four cups of
coffee a day as far as the statistics
are concerned four and twenty four are
the same thing yeah three and four are
worlds apart
yeah and 0.9 and 1.1 are equally worlds
apart yeah and so that is a huge
limitation when it comes to making
specific inferences about a number of
cups of coffee within those ranges
mm-hmm so I don't know a lot of people
who would at face value get on board
with the idea that 4 and 24 are the same
but the results of this paper you cannot
make any distinction between 4 and 24 25
so that's an important thing to keep in
mind when you look at this when you look
at these results the other important I
guess outcome as a result of this
grouping is again back to that question
who's actually drinking twenty five cups
a day without having all the data
available or you know a full detailed
description of the study in paper form
it's hard to be certain but most likely
almost nobody
yeah I mean it it was pretty clearly the
group that's four plus it's probably 95%
of the people in that group are
consuming between four and maybe eight
to ten cups of coffee a day exactly and
then you know then from 10 to 25 I'm not
saying there are no people that drink
that much but they would have been so
non plentiful within that group that
like their results would have
essentially not affected the outcome for
that group to any meaningful degree
whatsoever exactly so and to kind of
frame it a different way imagine we were
doing a study looking at diabetes risk
type 2 diabetes and we did it based on
BMI and we had a group that was less
than 25 BMI and a group that was over 25
if we look in that group over 25 and
let's say we had some arbitrary cutoff
where the BMI is 25 to 50 so if we were
to do that type of grouping and most of
our sent you know 95 percent of our
sample had a BMI at 26 and we had like
one person with a BMI alike 41 you would
not make the conclusion like oh it turns
out your type-2 diabetes risk isn't even
that bad if your BMI is 49 yeah no again
but exactly that's pretty much what
we're seeing here is like theoretically
there's a possibility that some small
percentage of the people of that group
actually were anywhere near 25 from from
what I saw in the abstract I don't think
you can be certain how many are actually
close but really what we're looking at
there is an effect that is almost
certainly driven by a bunch of people
that drink 4 to 6 cups of coffee a day
for sure maybe 4 to 8 yeah so the reason
that I get so into details because it's
not just about this it's not just about
caffeine and arterial stiffness this is
something that you see time and time
again in research especially in
epidemiology so it's important to take a
step back and whenever you see grouping
like this think what assumptions am i
inadvertently
agreeing to on the front end and so in
this case what you're agreeing to is the
idea that three cups and four cups are
wildly different and four and twenty
four are the same yeah and I think that
that's I think that that's one of like
the key differences between people who
read research and like understand what
they're reading versus people who just
kind of skim abstracts because like the
the results of a study have to be
interpreted in the context of what model
they used and like you said different
models have different types of
assumptions that you bring into it and
if a model has bad assumptions then it's
not going to be it's not going to be
very useful to you
or or at the very least you need to be
more skeptical of the results and maybe
not jump to the most radical possible
conclusion of the results that you could
jump to which in this case is your fine
drink in 25 cups of coffee a day exactly
again you know getting back to that
metaphor looking at type 2 diabetes risk
we've got a group under 25 and a group
from 25 to 50 if all those people in 25
to 50 group are like 26 or 27 they might
not have an elevated risk of diabetes
compared to the other group but the last
thing you would want to conclude from
that study is apparently a BMI of 50 is
totally fine you're not gonna get
diabetes there yeah and like just just
so the listeners know like that that's
not a wild metaphor here like like that
that is actually a really really good
metaphor for the types of conclusions
people are jumping to with this caffeine
study it's essentially the exact it's
I've just changed the name of variables
but that's yeah for sure it's it's just
like I I know that sometimes like for
myself for example I don't come up with
good metaphors on the spot and so like
what you're describing to the listeners
probably sounds completely outrageous
like there's no way someone would look
at that and say a BMI of 45 is
completely fine for diabetes risk so
like a lot of times if
if a metaphor sounds extreme people
immediately assume that it's not
actually a good metaphor for the thing
you're trying to make a point about so I
was just kind of like reinforcing and
reiterating like no that actually is a
really good metaphor like that sir
that's exactly what's going on here you
don't think I'm being emotional and
dramatic not this time
okay cool I've kept my hysteria in check
now the important thing is what do we
actually make of this we do have a
pretty big body of literature pertaining
to how caffeine actually relates to
cardiovascular risk a very big body of
literature going back multiple decades
now a lot of the early literature made
the conclusion that caffeine did you
know habitual coffee and other caffeine
intake did increase the risk of adverse
cardiovascular events so you know heart
attacks strokes things of that nature
now what research has shown us more
recently is that some of those
preliminary studies did not effectively
account for one very very glaring
correlation that we see in the coffee
literature people who drink a lot of
coffee tend to smoke a lot and so a lot
of the more recent research looking at
cardiovascular risk which kind of makes
sense and it does yeah
people who like uppers like uppers yeah
and so those are kind of the two best
legal uppers on the market you know yeah
and so it's one of those funny things
about research where in hindsight it's
like of course but you know when they
were doing the studies it's like what do
you want me to do I've got you know this
caffeine survey and all the people
drinking all the caffeine are having
heart attacks and so a lot of the more
recent studies have been a lot more
aware of this pretty high correlation
between caffeine intake and cigarette
use and the more recent studies are
actually showing in fact caffeine
doesn't seem to be particularly harmful
when it comes to long-term
cardiovascular risk when you look at
coffee and and caffeinated tea Entei
as a whole they actually have some
protective effects on a variety of
long-term health outcomes when consumed
in what most people would consider a
moderate intake range so if you're
drinking the caffeine equivalent of one
to like maybe five possibly six cups of
coffee a day you actually see a lot of
risk reductions when it comes to a lot
of long-term health outcomes and
mortality there once you start getting
beyond that five or six cup a day range
those protective effects seem to become
a little bit less apparent and my guess
would be that at that point you're also
dealing with other risk factors that you
may not be accounting for in the model
because because like dude as as someone
who really likes caffeine the only time
I personally would be consuming six or
more cups a day is like if I'm stressed
out of my mind and super sleep-deprived
like there's there's no other reason
that I would consume that much and I'm
someone who loves caffeine so yeah so
that kind of makes me think that at that
in like you know maybe there's some
other [ __ ] going on that you're not
accounting for yeah so know one caveat
to that there's a paper that said if you
are a fast caffeine metabolizer you're
probably fine when it comes to coffee
and caffeine intake with cardiovascular
risk but if you're genetically a slow
caffeine metabolizer you actually might
have an increased risk when it comes to
negative cardiovascular outcomes
long-term however I believe a more
recent paper failed to replicate that
particular finding I think there is a
paper within the last year yeah that
that retested that finding and said from
our from our results that doesn't really
seem to be the case so that is still
kind of up in the air when it comes to
determining exactly how we use the
information we have about caffeine
genotype and how that relates to not
just long-term health outcomes but even
the performance effects of caffeine
there's some research saying that your
your genotype for the cyp 1a2 gene might
influence a whole variety of outcomes
when it comes to your caffeine responses
quick question did and I don't know how
how much depth you looked into the these
papers in but did they control for oral
contraceptive usage I don't know off the
top of my head so one of the things that
I recently learned and by recently I
mean like three days ago is that that's
apparently a pretty big deal for
caffeine metabolism oh definitely yeah I
was completely unaware of that something
else I learned is that eating
specifically char grilled beef slows
down caffeine metabolism yes it's a wild
yes I have no idea so when I was an
undergraduate doing my undergraduate
degree they made us take a pharmacology
course and what you find out very
quickly in a pharmacology course is that
the p450 enzyme system in the liver is
kind of the big catch-all for all the
[ __ ] you're throwing at your body like
if something needs to be dealt with
there's a high likelihood that the p450
enzymes are gonna have to figure that
out
mm-hm and so you know caffeine is
metabolized primarily by you know cyp
one a to a particular p450 enzyme and
there are a tremendous amount of
interactions of different not just drugs
but also foods all sorts of things you
can do that affect the cytochrome p450
system something i think i think one of
the classic ones a lot of people are
aware of is grapefruit juice yep
slows down the metabolism of caffeine
yeah and so there are some things you
can do some things you can ingest that
either slow down or increase the rate of
caffeine metabolism based on how they
affect that whole enzyme system as a
whole
so yeah grapefruit juice charred meat
estrogen in general so throughout you
know things like pregnancy throughout
the münster
cycle the it's quite sensitive to
fluctuations in sex hormones there are a
whole list of fruits and vegetables
don't--don't cruciferous vegetables
affected as well yes cruciferous
vegetables yeah man I wonder if that if
that has anything to do with the
popularity of coffee and caffeine in
like physique sports because like the
classic bodybuilder meal of like chicken
rice and broccoli a lot of physique
athletes are eating a ton of cruciferous
vegetables and also drinking a lot of
coffee yeah and I wonder if those two
things are related I would say as an
elite to sport athlete in their physique
sport realm you drink coffee during prep
because it's your only source of joy
that is still there everything else has
been taken from you I don't get prep I
don't think it's just a prep thing
though okay yeah I will say in in prep
usually people take their normal coffee
intake and double or triple it mm-hmm
but you know you're right even in the
offseason it is quite quite popular I
mean I it's it's just kind of the case I
think that strength at like strength
like resistance training that people
just love caffeine and ice people do
right you know maybe but I think that
it's particularly the case for
resistance training folks like one of
yeah one of the worst kept secrets or
maybe best kept secrets is that a lot of
like Olympic weightlifters are
chainsmokers which like you can kind of
get away with that because a lot of the
stuff you're doing is like low rep and
whatnot so you're not gonna be like
huffing and puffing like you may after
like a set of 15 squats or something
like that but you just don't see in
terms of how like strength and physique
athletes abuse their bodies with
stimulants you don't see anything
remotely similar in any other sport that
I'm aware of like that that's all that's
all I'm saying and so I wonder if
there's like I wonder if there's like a
neuro chemistry thing where like the
folks who are crazy enough to be drawn
to like elite strength sports and or
just like crazy levels of risk
straining if like that interacts with
like a similar type of crazy to make you
also really enjoy uppers you've actually
you've really opened my eyes in this
conversation so I've been lifting since
I was twelve I started strength coaching
at eighteen I did ten years of college
in this area everything I did as a hobby
outside of college was in this area and
I just realized when I said I think
everybody in general is just really into
caffeine I don't think I know anyone
that's not enough lifting but it's been
like for me it's been like God 15 years
or more of just only doing lifting stuff
for work and enjoying it
mm-hmm but now that I think about it be
like rare human interaction that I have
outside of lifting has been on just like
going on dates and stuff like that was
people who aren't into lifting and I
they were all weirded out by how much I
always needed coffee around now that I
think about it like what's wrong with
you and like what do you mean everyone
lives from coffee cup to coffee cup and
they're like no not really
yes so I mean I don't know if like maybe
I'm just trying to like justify things
to myself maybe the two of us are just
like outlier caffeine addicts but it has
been my observation that like folks who
are into lifting really regardless of
what lifting endeavor it is just like
uppers and like specifically caffeine
and coffee more like considerably more
than the population as a whole like that
there there are there are multiple
coffee companies that like are
associated with like lifestyle brands
for lifters there's caffeine and kilos I
have a bag of brick house coffee
downstairs right now I've got sent that
for free so little plug in return it's
quite good
I enjoy it there's one so it people who
want to send free stuff that's a free
plug going off to a hundred million
listeners right now hell yeah like that
mind
I think like Deathwish coffee primarily
advertises to like CrossFit folks okay
that makes sense but yeah I mean like
there's a huge culture around like
caffeine and coffee and in particular in
strength sports like in a way that I
haven't seen for people with like other
hobbies yeah well we're gonna put that
to the test because by the time this
podcast airs stronger by science calm
we'll have a really big comprehensive
caffeine article going up that basically
tells you everything that a lifter would
want to know about caffeine so we will
put that to the test and see exactly how
much how many views that particular
article gets but well we'll see how
crazy people are about their caffeine
hell yeah
now before we move on I just want to put
a little bow on this conversation
we've talked a lot about some of the you
know I don't want to beat up these
researchers because what they've done
with this grouping approach is extremely
common extremely common especially in
epidemiology so it's not like we're like
whoa what are these idiots doing like
this is kind of how business is done
in that area you could argue they should
have left the variable continuous and
done other approaches to modeling so if
you're a stat nerd I'm not going to get
into detail about this but if you're
worried that leaving it continuous might
introduce non-linearity into your model
you can include different polynomial
terms into your model you can also use
something called spline regression that
allows for some breakpoints within the
model
so for the three of you listening out
there you can go Google that there's a
lot of good stuff out there but um to
wrap things up can we be certain or at
all confident that 25 cups a day of
coffee fails to increase any risk when
it comes to cardiovascular health
we cannot be confident in that based on
on this particular abstract I still
based on the whole body of literature
leading up to it I'm still of the
opinion that if you're drinking the
caffeine equivalent of anywhere from one
to five cups of coffee a day you might
see some slight protective benefits or
at least a minimal harm once you start
drifting beyond five or six cups a day
you're kind of in an
known area but I would tend it for a
million other reasons suggest probably
capping it at the five to six a day
range unless you really really really
need to get bailed out of a jam yeah I
mean like once you start talking about
more than that regardless of what time
of day you're consuming it it's probably
gonna [ __ ] up your sleep yeah cuz like
caffeine has a reasonably long half-life
yeah if you're putting down you know if
you're putting down a gram of caffeine
at 10:00 in the morning you probably
still have like 250 milligrams in your
system at like 8:00 that night when
you're hopefully trying to think about
winding down and that's that that's the
caffeine equivalent of like downing 2
cups of coffee at 8:00 p.m. yeah and and
that's the thing that a lot of people
miss about caffeine is I often hear
people say I drink a lot of coffee I can
drink it and go right to bed like I'm
not at all worried about having it late
in the day because I'll sleep fine the
half-life of caffeine is usually
estimated somewhere around five six
hours give or take but if you look in
the literature you can find studies
suggesting it's as low as two or three
or as high as twelve because there's a
ton of variability there in how rapidly
people metabolize caffeine and so
something to keep in mind is the
half-life is a thing so you if you drink
it a ton of caffeine and your final
caffeine dose is coming at 4:00 p.m.
it's you're gonna have a substantial
amount of caffeine in your system when
you go to bed and more importantly just
because you fell asleep
doesn't mean you slept well and so I
think a lot of people trick themselves
into thinking I don't have to worry
about this half-life I can drink
caffeine very late in the day because I
know I'll get to bed in reality there's
probably a high likelihood that even
though you manage to fall asleep you
probably had a non-negligible negative
impact on your sleep quality
yeah it'll it'll decrease deep sleep
it'll decrease REM sleep if you're
if you're someone who consumes a lot of
caffeine and you habitually get like a
good night of sleep and still wake up
feeling really really tired the next day
it's probably worth experimenting on
cutting back a little bit and and
cutting off caffeine a little bit
earlier in the day just just to see if
that affects like subjectively how you
feel upon waking yeah I mean if any of
my coaching clients tell me they have
sleep issues that the very first thing I
say is how much caffeine are you having
and when is it getting ingested like
even if it's not right before bed it
could be making an impact and we were
looking at a paper the other day on Thea
Crean which is very similar in structure
to caffeine which means that it has a
lot of similar effects on the body one
of the differences it has is its
half-life and I was reading a paper that
was basically suggesting like oh it's
got this extended half-life which is
awesome because then it's gonna be you
know more time of having a stimulant in
your system and I was looking at that
paper and I was like how am I supposed
to believe it was it like a 24 26 hour
half-life for a stimulant wait I thought
you said it was like 16 it might have
been whatever it was it was a
double-digit half life yeah I forget the
exact number I remember it like you
could you consume a fair dose of it
first thing when you wake up in the
morning you'll probably have at least a
quarter of that dose still in your
system then next morning yeah and so
like it's kind of new so we'll see if if
more research comes out seeing oh
actually for for you know chemistry is
pretty wild biochemistry and maybe
there's some mechanism by which people
are able to avoid sleep issues with it
it's way too early to tell with that
it's not like caffeine where we actually
have studies directly looking at that
but um the moral of the story is who's
drinking 25 cups of coffee a day
probably nobody does 25 cups a day
increase arterial stiffness we probably
don't know because probably very few
people in that sample actually did that
we are probably looking at the effects
of actually drinking like 46
today yeah and extrapolating that to 25
and in conclusion if you're worried
about your long-term health risks and
how caffeine might affect them getting
your caffeine primarily from coffee and
tea and keeping it in the equivalent of
like 1 to 5 maybe 1 to 6 cups of coffee
a day it's probably going to be the
ideal strategy and not having them right
before bed is always preferable if you
look at a lot of papers on caffeine
they're pretty much gonna tell you that
they all say 400 milligrams a day or
less some of them go as high as 600 but
I've never in my life seen a you know a
thorough comprehensive review paper that
says you know what would that be 2,500 a
day at 25 cups of coffee yeah there
abouts yeah I haven't seen 2,500 today 6
600 is as bold as I've seen God that's
wild
it is wild indeed so I'm looking at a
caffeine article for mass this month as
well when are you looking at the Skinner
paper looking at sex differences oh okay
yeah so hot off the presses
study called women experienced the same
origin ik response to caffeine as men
which first let me just take exception
with what the researchers did here I
wanted to tell you about this study and
give you the results and they didn't put
a spoiler warning on the title and so
like now now you guys you guys know how
this is gonna go so there's there's no
there's no suspense there's no build-up
I hate when they do that it's like when
we saw that movie called The Avengers
and I knew surely they're going to
avenge whatever someone's gonna get an
inch yeah it's ridiculous anyway so this
was this was a depressingly important
paper and the reason I say it's
depressingly important is there is a
very considerable amount of research
looking at the ergogenic effects of
caffeine and
the vast vast majority of that research
has been performed in only male subjects
and so like the thing with with Exercise
Science is there is a sex gap in terms
of like the subjects and studies and
it's not as bad as it used to be so like
Risa I think the most recent paper
looking at this was published in like
2014 and it found that it was like kind
of a 60/40 split about 60% of the
subjects are men about 40% are women
should probably be closer to 5050 but
like honestly like 6040 is not terrible
it used to be closer to like 80/20 70/30
going back 15 20 years so like things
are improving but looking at the field
as a whole is kind of myopic so the the
gap the sex gap in participants varies
considerably depending on what research
question you're talking about so when
you look at like the sarcopenia
literature or like the osteoporosis
literature you see a lot of female
subjects and for osteoporosis you see
more female subjects than male subjects
but then like especially a fair amount
of resistance training like quite a few
questions within resistance training and
especially for a lot of like like
supplementation niches you see like a
much more well-defined gap in terms of
how many studies use male subjects
versus how many use female and caffeine
was a supplement where that was
particularly notable and so this was
actually the first study using both male
and female subjects that had them
perform the same actual like exercise
testing protocol to compare directly
like do women also have a similar
increase in performance to to caffeine
as men do so like do they also have an
increase and is that increase similar to
to what you see in men because yeah we
have a ton of research showing that in
mostly men caffeine is good causes
genik effects but not as much in women
in in precious little directly comparing
than in women and so this study let me
just start off by saying it was
exquisitely well controlled which is
awesome they made sure hydration was
consistent for the 24 hours prior to
testing sessions they fed the subjects a
standardized diet to make sure that
wouldn't affect things they fed them a
standardized meal before the study
started they made sure that all testing
took place at the same time of day like
they really dotted their eyes and cross
their T's when it came to controlling
all relevant variables and what they did
is they had all of the subjects complete
complete two time trials the the
distance of the time trials was I
believe 75% of the individuals peak
sustainable power output times 3,600
that was like the total amount of work
they needed to complete and in one
session they gave people a placebo in
the other session they gave them three
milligrams per kilogram of caffeine and
they were just looking the the primary
variable they were looking at was time
trial performance so how long it took to
complete that amount of work and then
they were also looking at caffeine
metabolism so what caffeine levels in
the blood or in the plasma looked like
the for exercise and also after exercise
they also took heart rate and rpe
measurements as well so long story short
they found that women did experience the
same Herger genic effects of caffeine is
mended so the average increase in
performance in men was like four point
three percent for women it was like four
point six percent
those weren't significantly different
obviously and they were both significant
increases within each group as I
mentioned earlier on the podcast I
recently learned that
contraceptives had a had a big increase
on caffeine metabolism all of the women
in that in this study were on the pill
and they tested them during the high
hormone phase of their pill to try to
standardize hormone levels between the
women as well as possible
they found that pre exercise caffeine
levels were similar in men and women but
for the men caffeine levels in plasma
were basically flat pre to post exercise
and for women it actually increased from
pre to post pretty considerably so that
maybe suggest like slower uptake and and
also slower metabolism
however blood caffeine levels weren't
correlated with the the relative
magnitude of benefit people saw from the
caffeine supplementation and then in
terms of heart rate RPE rate of
perceived exertion was the same in both
sexes regardless of whether they were on
caffeine or the placebo which is very
consistent with prior research so
basically what you tend to see is that
if people are doing like a fixed
workload in a fixed amount of time
caffeine supplementation decreases
perception of effort if you're if it's
something like this where it's kind of
maximal output you're trying to complete
a set amount of work as quick as
possible what you tend to see is better
performance with the same perception of
effort so that was consistent with prior
research and the same in both sexes here
and then also which I mean that would
kind of make sense yeah like if you're
going all out and trying to do it as
quick as possible like it's gonna be
[ __ ] hard it's going to suck yeah
yeah no matter what you're on yeah so
yeah like like for submaximal stuff
caffeine tends to make things feel
easier for maximal it still feels hard
as [ __ ] you're just better yeah and then
for heart rate average heart rate
increased a little more for men than
women in this study which was
interesting it increased by about seven
beats per minute in
which was a significant difference and
only about two beats per minute in women
which I think may have been like barely
significant like P between point O four
and point O five but I'm to two beats
per minute is effectively nothing so
yeah this like I said was an important
paper because in some areas of the
literature there's a lot of research on
men and we look at it and we just kind
of have to hope and assume that it
applies to women as well and so when we
get a study like this bridging the gap
showing that like hey when we look at
aerobic performance we've we've tested
this considerably on men before in
isolation and have tested it a few times
in women in isolation but now when we
test them head-to-head together we see
similar effects both in terms of the
type of effects you see and the
magnitude of the effects that can make
you a little more comfortable that the
rest of the research findings that we've
seen previously in men probably will
apply to women as well for caffeine for
caffeine right yeah which is big because
so much work has gone into establishing
this entire body of caffeine literature
and yeah until we see more of these very
tightly controlled kind of within the
study showing those same types of
effects that gives us a lot more
confidence yeah and there's there's a
finite amount of research funding and so
you don't want to have to take 20 years
of research conducted on men and say
like [ __ ] we should have looked at women
as well and then spend like 20 more
another 20 years and a whole bunch of
like resources running back all of those
same studies you know so when we can get
a study like this that bridges the gap
that shows like oh man there was a there
was a glaring oversight in the research
previously we really should have checked
this out in women as well if you test it
and then it's like oh we're seeing big
differences then it's like well now it's
time to be skeptical of this whole body
of literature and whether it will
generalize to women or not but but when
you see it when you see similar effects
in men and women it gives you a little
more confidence so like okay
like we have this pretty big body of
literature it's it's probably going to
apply pretty similarly to both sexes
it's particularly important when you
consider how variable the caffeine
literature is in terms of just what we
are looking at you know so we have so
much literature looking at the timing of
doses how high doses should be time
trial performance for endurance
submaximal performance for long
durations for endurance vertical jump 1
rep max reps to fatigue sprint peak
power sprint mean power I feel like to
someone who's not familiar with the
literature it's like who cares if we
have to do a few more studies and women
to replicate all of it and it's like no
if we can do one study to give us
confidence that all these things will
translate that's gonna save us as a
field so much time so much money so many
headaches oh that that's why there are
no critical and and and one thing to
note here dear listener is you may be
listening to this and thinking that that
were maybe being a little overconfident
because like you know this is primarily
like a lifting podcast like Eric's a
bodybuilder I'm a power lifter most you
guys are probably into strength and
physique sports in some way shape or
form so it's like why are you
generalizing this much from a study on
aerobic performance and my answer to
that would be I assume assume your
caffeine article is gonna be out by the
time that this episode goes up so yeah
so check out the article that Eric wrote
about caffeine how it affects
performance and the mechanisms by which
it does so the cool thing about caffeine
is it has beneficial effects on a very
wide variety of like types of exercise
but the core mechanism which is
adenosine antagonism seems to be the
same mechanism by which it improves all
of those different facets of performance
so if you can nail down that like ok we
know that this mechanism improves all of
these different types of performance we
know that caffeine affects this
mechanism and now that we see like it
effects
performance and therefore probably this
mechanism the same in both sexes in like
one aspect of performance since it's the
same mechanism it it probably
generalizes you you very much can't make
that statement about some other type of
supplement that maybe has like multiple
different primary mechanisms of action
and like maybe improves aerobic
performance in one way and strength
performance in another way but with
caffeine it has that one core mechanism
so like things seem to generalize pretty
well and that's one of the reasons why
it's been so successful at improving so
many different kinds of performance from
everything from like one rep max to very
very long duration aerobic performance
yeah it's an incredibly versatile
ingredient but it's it all comes back to
the adenosine antagonism so yeah to see
that a tightly controlled study like
this show so much overlap between the
male response and the female response is
pretty huge all right well I think that
might be a probably a good time to wrap
up this episode I noticed you took a jab
at me you said I was a bodybuilder when
you know that I'm also a classic
bodybuilder so usually when things get
testy in the recording studio it's time
to call it whether I narrowly refer to
Bo Jackson as a football player that's
not a jab at Bo Bo still knows goddamn
it okay but whenever things get testy
it's time to kind of cool things down
and take a break maybe take a walk so
for this episode we've got an awesome
interview we've talked a little bit in
this podcast about some crazy feats of
strength we've also talked about more
female specific aspects of research and
the fact that it's kind of challenging
using some of the the research that's
available to make recommendations for
women because there are a lot of gaps
there you know kind of uneven treatment
so to speak
now we sat down and had an interview
with Natalie Hansen and first of all she
was still still kind of buzzing about
she had just recently won the world
benchpress championships over
in Tokyo I believe yeah so we talked to
her about her own and had to set a crazy
PR to do so yeah very crazy PR so she
shared some strength feats of her own
and then she also talked to us a little
bit about unique challenges that women
face in the fitness and more
specifically the powerlifting world so
it's a very very good complementary
interview to pair up with this podcast
so we had a great time talking and
Natalie we hope you'll enjoy it and we
will see you after the music
[Music]
[Music]
Natalie thank you for joining us
how's life a life is good I'm pretty
jet-lagged we just got back from Japan
two nights ago so it's that's hit me
pretty hard
what was that traveling for for business
or pleasure um I mean I suppose it's a
little bit of both when you're competing
so I competed at IPF equipped bench
worlds in Tokyo oh I saw you uh you one
right bench - OH - yeah it was crazy it
was white it was wild I'm still kind of
like in disbelief about it I so so I
briefly saw some highlights of that on
on reddit I believe I think that's a
good place to start though do you want
to just give the listeners a
play-by-play yeah um and it's only a
three lift meet so it's easy for
play-by-play
oh so going in I I did USA powerlifting
open Nationals exactly two weeks prior
and that we considered that my kind of
training test for bench worlds I've
never done bench worlds before I have
gotten the invitation a couple different
times and just it's not a priority of
mine so I usually turn it down but when
when I got an invitation for Tokyo I was
like I can't really pass that up so we
did a training test at Nationals I hit
190 2.0 it was not easy it was like a
max effort lift and so I think going
into bench worlds we were like well you
know I'm not gonna have squatted 265
prior and I'll have you know that whole
week basically of tapered I'm not gonna
be squatting or dead lifting really at
all and so I'm gonna be all fresh and
ready to go but still you know maybe
another five kilos going into the meet
but I I said like I'm not here I was
nominated second and I said I'm not here
to take second like I don't I'm not
really interested in messing around with
anything beyond below first place so
it was it was pretty wild I I had to cut
more than normal just because of the
travel I retained more water than I
normally do and so the night before I
was doing a water cut and kind of in
unfamiliar circumstances getting ready
for a bench only meet where I'm not you
know super female super familiar with
the environment we had a flight of 20
lifters so a lot of things that were
just different then I didn't really know
what to expect of myself we opened at
the heaviest I said I was comfortable
opening because with a three lifts or a
single lift me the strategy is all about
lifting position and ideally if you're
competing with somebody you want to be
lifting after them so if you get if you
have a lower lot number at weigh ins
then you want to open heavier than them
ideally so that you can watch where they
go I told the coaches that I wasn't
comfortable opening with anything higher
than 185 kilos which is 407 and that
ended up being the second second
heaviest opener behind or you know
second to a this Russian girl who she
just benched 147 and a half kilos raw
earlier in the meet so she's like this
strong chick she's yeah so she opened I
think at 187 or something like that and
we just kind of based on my opening the
opener speed just went to 190 it was I
was a little more tentative on it than I
should have been or than I normally
would be but that's kind of the nature
of just trying to get the openers like
I'd rather have it be a little bit more
difficult and make it clean than risk
risk a miss and things can go wrong
really quickly with a quick bench so you
just have to be careful went 190 she
also went 190 on her second and I just
destroyed it like the best it's ever
moved for me and I was like alright this
is it's game on
and she was really strong too she she's
pressed it like no problem well what
happened is we have a team of USA
coaches that are really skilled in
calling numbers at bench meets and I
think they the Russian coaches may have
been less experienced or just didn't
realize that I was coming to like like
uh battle with her they maybe they
thought that I was just going to take
you know another two or five and just
kind of be done yeah so so they bumped
her up to 202 and a half I believe and
then basically they made the wrong call
on her third attempt initially so you
get two changes just like you do on
deadlifts and a powerlifting meet you
get ages on the third bench and they put
in the wrong number it was a number that
was gonna be I think lower than my third
plan and then they had to submit their
change right then so they burned a
change right off the bat and coaches
were like that's when they were like all
right let's go so they put in 205 for my
third and you know I'm just like I felt
so good on my second that I felt like my
ceiling was pretty high but I told him
like whatever it takes and so she
dropped to 201 point five and then I
dropped also to two a 1.5 and so
basically whoever's the lift first
lifter is if she break if she hits it
then I bump up to 202 like that
automatically happens yeah and we in the
you know meanwhile there was a Norwegian
who was really strong and she was she
had missed her opener and that kind of
threw her off but she was taking 190 on
her third which would have tied me and
she would have beat me on body weight if
I were to have missed my third so we had
to watch the Norwegian first and and
then make the call for what we were
gonna do on mine because if she pressed
190 then I was gonna have to just go 192
and a half and just secure silver she
missed it and so the coaches then they
were like alright we're going for it
gold medal and world
so the Russian goes first with 201 and a
half she kills it and then I took 202
and you know pressed it and it was crazy
my coach was my personal coach was
texting the coaches and he said you know
I think she's 5050 with 195 and or 197
and a half and they were all kind of
like yeah she's maybe got 197 in half
but two of two's a reach and it was a it
was really nice like I keep watching it
and I'm just like I don't know where
that came from but apparently I've been
sandbagging so so was that like a 10
kilo PR for you yeah 10 kilo PR after
and I've never pressed 202 or anything
over I've never done over 190 two and a
half full range so I've done that two
boards and stuff but I've never taken
that to my chest anything more than then
192 and a half yeah it makes it even
more crazy I think that's wild that's
like that's like Steiners third attempt
clean-and-jerk
back in Beijing or wherever that's
awesome though it's like a total a total
like Hail Mary so where do you think it
came from do you think it was just like
just rising to the moment of the
competition or do you think that like
maybe 200 was a number that had been in
your head that like scared you a little
bit and that just kind of forced you to
go over it like do you do you do you
miss in training is it something like
you tried 195 several times before and
missed it or no no so my training is
pretty conservative that I'll have one
essentially like test week before a
competition three weeks out and I hit
depending on how trainings been going
I'll hit anywhere between you know 97
and 102 percent of my my PR my best
bench enough in a meet prior to
Nationals was one ninety one point five
in Arnold in 2018 so it had been about a
year I don't really miss in training if
I'm isn't raining it's because I it's
technical like I've you know I pulled
the shirt down too much or I was too
hesitant and I you know miss groove and
and it's all like technique based and a
lot of times so for example in my
training cycle for nationals I kind of
can we can I use cuss words on this
podcast exclusively uses cuss words this
is this is only a family-friendly
podcast if all of the kids had moved out
of the house okay
so I totally ate [ __ ] with one night one
eighty seven and a half and I sent the
video to my coach and he said you pulled
your shirt down too much load 190 and I
loaded 190 and stroked it so that's the
kind of thing that will happen is like
it's not really ever like I can't press
it out it's just that I like I [ __ ] up
on my end so that's kind of the gist of
it I've had a couple of really
interesting training sessions with a guy
named Mike wall Mac he's the owner of
the bench daddy if you guys are photo
yeah and he's a multi ply bench coach
and adventurer and I've had two sessions
with him when I've been in Texas
previously and he he kind of reframed in
my mind what's like humanly possible for
me so I want the last time I was I did a
training session with him he loaded 225
kilos and I took it for a double to a
one board I think if I remember
correctly it so like I don't ever really
think that I'm not like oh now I can
bench 225 like I come out of that with
like just kind of a better understanding
of like what I'm capable of holding in
my hands you know obviously I pressed it
it's just a it's a different mindset and
so I'm not really afraid of 200 kilos
like I've never been like that's a scary
load I don't want to see that on the bar
I think it just comes from it just it
just came from I'm really pretty
experienced on the international stage
at this point but I've never been I've
never been challenged on the
international stage to the point where
after like make a lift to
you know to get a certain placing
introduction it was like maybe maybe it
was just kind of like this thing that's
been pent up that I haven't really been
able to use and I finally got to use it
so yeah I was more like just them in the
moment kind of gamer mentality and like
I'm not here for a second place like and
I'm and I don't really have any fears of
what's gonna happen if I don't press
this I got you that that makes sense
that's awesome so so just just for the
listeners if you don't know who Mike
Womack is and correct me if I'm wrong on
this Natalie isn't he the first guy to
ever bench nine hundred and single-ply
um maybe I feel like I should know that
he was he was like he's past his prime
now but he was definitely one of the
best like five or so super heavyweight
equipped ventures back in like the late
the late Ott's and like early 20 teens
yeah that sounds about right
he's he's like some of the things I
would hear him he would tell me when we
trained together I'm just kind of like
that I don't I can't comprehend how that
works but I'm gonna just do it because
you're telling me to do it and then you
know it kind of like I I would come away
from those sessions like with my mind
blown like yeah it was I mean
immediately for the first time I worked
with him was like a month out from 2017
nationals and my bench was just kind of
like meh like you know mid somewhere
around 150 160 kilos kind of kind of
stuck there and I benched 175 at that
meet and it was like like I don't know
where that came from but but I did it so
that's that's kind of how my where a lot
of my kind of fearlessness on equipped
benches come from is those sessions with
Mike because I'm always like I've done
30 kilos more than this with Mike so I
got you that makes sense so how how much
do you get out of your equipment cuz you
you either do compete raw or have
competed raw as well right
yeah so most recently
I think I get probably 80 kilos out of a
bench shirt mm-hmm which is I think
that's pretty high for somebody for like
an on you know 120 or 120 plus guy
that's a high percentage out of my squat
suit my best squat like all-time PR is
197 and a half raw I haven't worked up
to a raw max since 2016 so I I just
legitimately don't know but I you know I
squat 270 my best squat us to 73 to 75
in training so that's a that's a lot
I don't can't do the math off the top of
my head deadlift suit is almost like
backwards it's like you know zero to
sometimes even negative kilos it just
makes it it makes deadlifting suck a
little bit less so I gotcha that makes
sense it so it sounds like I mean like
obviously you're strong as [ __ ] like no
matter how you slice or dice it but it
sounds like on top of that you're quite
the technician with the equipment as
well so like how what what sort of work
does it take for someone to get good
with equipment like I I know I've seen
so many raw lifters say like oh like the
gear does all the work for you like if I
threw on a squat suit like that I'd put
300 pounds on my squat just just
completely talking [ __ ] like one what is
that process like to get good dog yeah
it's it's long and kind of drawn-out and
I think that so I generally had pretty
good technique from when I started I had
a pretty solid athletic base and so I
was you know my my body awareness was
was decent as far what what is your
athletic background so I played
volleyball until I got to college and
then in college I did some club
volleyball and then I transitioned and
kind of stopped with the team sports and
started doing Crossfit gosh so I did
CrossFit for a few years and competed
and
like was you know I was pretty into it
and then when I realize like there's way
too much to get good at to be good at
CrossFit and I'm like stressed the the
variability stressed me out a whole lot
so that in powerlifting was like you
know inserted into my life and I was
like hey I've altima troll over
everything this is perfect so that that
was kind of the natural fit was to just
control almost every variable you know I
gotcha so yeah I think just from the
beginning my technique was was pretty
solid on the big three deadlift like I
said deadlift is always kind of an
exception to to this stuff for me
because it's much more reliant on your
leverages but yeah I mean squatting came
naturally to me and then I think I just
got more serious about squatting because
I was good at it and so I was like this
is I like this one and just mostly like
probably over analysis and kind of
obsession with making things always look
the same and that took years and I did
that you know I did that when I was a
raw lifter - and I even when I was you
know brand new raw lifter and I thought
I would see something weird happening
with my technique and I would you know
ask my coach like what's going on here
and he's like God like don't worry about
it you're just you know you're kind of
over overthinking it just do the work
and you're gonna get stronger and I mean
there was some truth to that but I could
but I did always have this tendency to
get really really into the details of
what my lifts look like and just trying
to maintain as much consistency between
reps and sets as possible so that is
part of it
another part of it is as so far benching
is disciplined so I use so for a long
time so early on I were what's in F's
called an f6 men's shirt which is kind
of the lowest level of a bench shirt you
can get it's it's four
you know kind of for beginners and I saw
you know my first time it had been shirt
ever at the time I was benching 95 kilos
raw so 209 and the first time I ever put
in FX on I benched 315 and I don't
really know where that came from besides
some level of fearlessness in putting
315 on the bar and maybe stupidity I'm
not really sure but I but I did and so
then that was kind of this start to
equipt benching that really got me going
and after my couple of meats and an f6
everyone told me you know you upgrade to
a super katana now like that's the
higher level shirt it's it helps more
it's you know etc etc so I did that and
then my bench completely plateaued for
two years and I thought it would and I'm
like you know just trying to like figure
out my technique and figure out all this
stuff like oh maybe it's the training
maybe it's maybe we're peaking wrong
like whatever and it just couldn't
couldn't figure it out so I went back to
an f6 and then I hit a 15 kilo PR so I
think part of it is um learning learning
to experiment on yourself so what
someone else is answers to you know what
like what Blaine does in his training or
or what how he wears his gear what gear
he uses is not going to be the right
thing for the next person and I try to
preach that as much as possible to
people just that you have to be your own
kind of guinea pig because you might not
know what you know what you're capable
of if you're not just if you're just
kind of like doing what everyone else
says you should do so that's part of it
too is this I'm comfortable like
ordering something that might not you
know might not be what I'm used to or
might be kind of a against the the grain
or the conventional wisdom and just
taking it for a ride and seeing what
happens a lot of times that ends up not
helping but good to know that and then I
can kind of cross that off my my list of
potential options and and maybe come
back to it later but but yeah
realistically like
being willing to experiment on yourself
and just kind of trial and error until
you feel like you have it right I I
really like that answer because it
confirms my own biases like the the one
of the things I tell everyone is that
the general advice that's floating
around out there is generally good for
most people most of the time but to
really like maximize your training or
your technique for yourself as an
individual once he kind of get your feet
wet and have a decent idea of what
you're doing it's like it's 98%
troubleshooting mm-hmm and I find that
talking to really really good lifters
like they intuitively get that and then
a lot of other people are just afraid to
try anything that isn't what someone has
like explicitly recommended to them yeah
totally
I also part of me that kind of that
reliance on information from other
people like how much how much is that a
modern-day thing in the sport and how
much of that it like to do to social
media or just kind of like creating
these like idols in coaching and stuff
like that or and how much of it is being
in your bubble and just being
comfortable that's a good question I I
don't know because the the knee-jerk
response is like oh it's it's probably
due to social media and like
manufactured consent and like people get
big voices and then their followers were
like shout down everyone else who does
different things but like reading about
like old-school lifters it kind of
seemed to be the same sort of thing but
on like a smaller scale yeah like if
someone was like a super super
successful lifter or bodybuilder
basically like everyone in their gym and
like within their town would kind of
start training the same way oh yeah but
but maybe that led to more total
innovation because like you know now
there's like thousands of little pockets
of lifters that may all kind of be
blindly following some dude but it's
like a thousand small locusts --is of
information versus like you know two
dozen people with five hundred thousand
followers on Instagram you know so
I don't know that's a good question
though so I always go to well it's
probably social media reaction to almost
everything that doesn't make sense to me
well and the thing is it's it's hard to
even know on social media because the
people like like what you see on social
media isn't reflective of reality the
the folk the folks who do just
absolutely blindly follow what their
favorite lifter or coach does and says
like they could theoretically still be a
tiny minority of people and they're just
the most vocal social media commenters
so they look like the majority you know
yeah it's hard to parse that so you
you've won multiple world titles at this
point and said a bunch of Records what
would you say your favorite lift or
moment has been in power lifting up to
this point
um I mean one of the one of my favorite
is that that third bench last week I
just I haven't felt this kind of like
surreal feeling in a while and it was
that was I'm just kind of like I was
kind of just buzzing for days like I
just couldn't really believe it cuz it
was you know I surprised myself so
that's one of them I think that my other
another time that just kind of has stuck
out for me is is 2017 open worlds my
first world title so just a couple years
ago a year and a half ago I just had a
really really fantastic day and squatted
to 73 what was in a world record
squat off with a Ukrainian and ended up
coming away with the with the world
record on my 3rd with and then had a you
know decent bench day at the time I was
I think I benched 185 and then I just
pulled you know my dad lived as always I
come out with such like a big subtotal
that we don't really push the deadlift
so I pulled 215 that day I believe
and hit the world record total and it
was just kind of like a really really
rewarding experience I was I was nervous
I had a really crazy moment on my
opening squat where we mistimed my raps
and I guess I can tell that story a
little bit because pulling off that's
that opening squat was I think showed me
that I'm capable of a lot more than I
then I gave myself credit for but
basically the coaches communicated to
the person who was rapping my knees when
she should start wrapping my knees and I
don't really know what happened but they
were off by one lifter and so I know
that's that's the workers crap yes so we
were was in health in Pilsen Czech
Republic and it's an IPF meet so they're
really you know they're gonna follow the
one minute timer and there was a to get
onto the stage this made it worse to get
on the stage it was a really steep ramp
like really really steep like it would
be steep steep to walk up a this ramp
without any wraps on and now you have to
hotter up it like a penguin yeah so so
it's a steep ramp and then you have to
walk the platform is right in the middle
of this stage but they had pet they had
taped off this little like walkway up to
it where you went around to the back of
the platform and then onto the platform
and they weren't letting people go
straight from the kind of waiting area
straight onto the platform they said
they wanted it this certain way and so
during is the person who designed this
venue ever squat and wraps before
probably not they probably got like a
lot of entertainment out of watching
lifters walk waddle around over and over
I gods some some sick sense of humor
there so so I'm minding my own business
you know getting ready for my opening
squat because I had a feeling it was
gonna be a good day and my coach who's
the head coach of the national team
comes over and he's like pulling me out
of the chair and she's midway through
she's tied off one and she's like kind
of a third of the way through the other
wrap and I'm like what the [ __ ] are you
doing like getting like let me sit down
I'm getting my knees wrapped and he's
like
we gotta go I have headphones on so I
take the headphones off to try to figure
out what's going on and she's like
frantic and she's trying to tie off this
near AB as it's on I'm standing up and
she's like you know like kneeling on the
floor trying to tie it off and I still
don't understand what's happening and
they're like we got to go and I'm like
what the what the [ __ ] and so I get out
to the platform and I realize my name's
on the board and the timer is going and
I don't have my wrist strap I like this
is a complete [ __ ] show and I wattle
that oh and when when you said they were
a lifter off I thought you were saying
like in the opposite direction and you
were like sitting there with your knee
wraps on for like three minutes no
that's that's exactly how I interpreted
that to know either I mean I mean this
is this is equally bad yeah but just in
a very different way so I bottle to the
top of the ramp and I have my wrist
straps in my hands and I just haven't
quite gotten a chance to put them on yet
because they've been putting my straps
up and they're like assuring me up
they're basically carrying me up this
ramp get to the top I'm trying to put
the wrist straps on while walking up to
the platform and of course it's not
allowed and so the the technical
controllers like blocking me like a like
you know he's we're playing basketball
against each other or something and I'm
like wrapping my wrists as fast as I can
and the clock is just ticking down I'm
watching it
everyone's like in the audience yelling
like come on let's go like get to your
wrists Raptors were like what like how
did this happen this is this is total
[ __ ] so I essentially got this start
command with one second left on the
clock or the squat command and just
stroked it like I don't I and I was like
I don't know I couldn't even really
remember in the moment remember the
rules like what do I have to do here to
get this the squat command so I'm like I
just have to get my feet set relatively
in you know relatively in the right
place like as long as they're somewhat
at the right distance apart I don't
really care where my toes are like I'll
just you know stand it up and and we'll
figure this out on the second attempt
and sure enough I just got the start got
the squat command and went down and came
up and I was like I came off the
platform just like what in the hell did
you guys just do because there are
of you and you're too qualified to be
[ __ ] something up like so that was a
pretty pretty like special moment to me
to be able to pull that off with against
all odds essentially and then there I
told my coach after that I was like well
the rest day is gonna be easy because
that was insane and you know he just he
he's a pretty like serious guy but you
know he just kind of got a kick out of
that one and and we moved on and it was
a great day so that's awesome so this is
somewhat of a change of subject and
mostly a question for me that none of
the listeners may be interested in but
one of the things I've noticed just kind
of in observing trends in the support of
powerlifting is is the sport has kind of
exploded in recent years but the vast
majority of the people entering the
sport tend to gravitate towards raw
lifting and so like that talent pool is
growing dramatically and I'm still
seeing like records falling and
performance is improving in single-ply
but but not at the same rate which kind
of makes sense because like most of the
athlete pool explosion has been in raw
but one thing I have noticed is that
there seem to be like a very
disproportionate number of single-ply
bench records falling so like I don't
live in that world and so I'm just
curious like where has this bench mojo
come from like has there been new
equipment released or approved by the
IPF like has training for the benchpress
changed in the IPF like do you have any
insight into what could be behind that
um I don't know so so we we do know
about how from the 90s to now the single
ply equipment has gotten much more
serious basically they say that in the
90s and even early 2000s a bench shirt
would just be you know kind of
equivalent to a slingshot or a ram today
and they were stretchy and
not nearly what they are now I think
that that kind of wave of improvements
has passed but I but I do think if you
consider how recent that change still
was people are probably still figuring
out how to appropriately wear those
shirts and max them out so and you know
kind of optimize their technique in them
and the training so so we did see a
general improvement in bench
performances from that change in
equipment but I think we're seeing that
kind of further tick up more at a more
sustainable rate as people are getting
their kind of figuring things out but
but I don't think it's been I mean I
might be wrong but I don't think it's
been that remarkable in the last you
know six or eight years obviously uh
Blanes 1,000 bench is crazy but you know
he's in he's an outlier in so many ways
so the world record that I just broke
was almost a ten-year old record in my
in the 84 kilo class so I think they're
I don't know it's hard to say I think it
has some to do with the equipment
getting more intense and probably people
figuring out their training and figuring
out how to you know learning new methods
so we have always heard about for
example the Japanese bench method is
different from you know the Western
approach and and maybe if information
like that is kind of being it's kind of
trickling into what we understand as
conventional like the technique and and
training styles and maybe that's
changing things but but yeah it has not
been as substantial as when shirt
materials changed and what the IPF
approved has changed oh no for sure for
sure like not not anywhere to the same
degree and and my observations could be
completely off and maybe like they're
being excessively swayed by blame like
dude I I remember watching meets back
and like I don't know maybe 2000 says
or so and still like no one had benched
800 in the IPF yet and then like brian
ciders benched 800 a couple times but
his head came up so he got red lights
and people were very outraged about that
and like now like blaine wouldn't even
consider that as like a possible opener
he's opening like a hundred pounds above
them yeah it's crazy yeah I know he's
crazy and what he's doing is setting the
bar higher you know just like the the
four-minute mile like he's setting he's
setting the standard higher and that's
what people are chasing they're not
chasing an 800 pound bench anymore
they're chasing a 900 pound bench and
then he he also has the single lift
bench record with that 1,000 three bench
and so he's setting that bar higher for
those guys too so I think that part of
it is you know some kind of freaks in
the sport continuing to raise the bar
and that just creates a hunger for much
higher numbers than we otherwise would
be chasing now I I did have a question
for you
if you don't mind Greg while we're on
the topic of equipment the Greg had
mentioned you have competed both raw and
equipped but where do you see yourself
competing moving forward um I like I
like equipment I just find it much more
thrilling and maybe I'm like some kind
of crazy adrenaline junkie but I I'm
fascinated by the kind of never-ending
pursuit of technical perfection and
figuring out all these little like
variables that that I can manipulate and
control and raw just doesn't really do
that for me I mean I you know you have
to realize like half of my training each
week is in even in my like the peak of
my equipped equipped preparation for a
competition like my training is still
50% or more raw and so I do get a pretty
decent dose of raw training on a regular
basis and it just doesn't really give me
that same thrill so it's more of like an
emotional kind of fixation on things
and less about like anything physical
necessarily but also I mean it's so much
it's a lot more fun to squat 600 pounds
than 400 pounds so I can imagine so I
could be very behind the times on this
when I was putting some questions
together for this interview I was going
to ask you about beef puffed barbell and
when I googled that
Corvus strength is the first thing that
came up and I noticed that that's now
your your email address as well yeah so
is is Corvis strength a new thing is it
like a rebranded beef puffed barbell and
what's kind of like the meaning and
history behind behind your business yeah
so Corvis strength co is the rebranded
version of beef puffed barbell that just
happened you're not that far behind the
times it just happened in April okay I
feel I feel less bad now yeah yeah yeah
yeah so so originally beef puffed
barbell started in late 2016 we
officially launched January 1st of 2017
it started kind of in for two reasons
first we were used a couple of my my
former business partner and I and a
friend were using this funny hashtag on
on Instagram
beef puffs like we were like we're beefy
and puffy and like you know this is this
is cool and it was cute and people
really liked it
and started asking us why don't you make
t-shirts that say that and we're kind of
like you know I don't we don't really
want to have an apparel company but at
the same time we were noticing around us
this is late 2016 that there just
weren't really a lot of female strength
coaches at the table
kept being you know taken seriously and
being considered legitimate resources of
information and so with though both of
those things in mind we decided to start
the brand beef puffed barbell and so we
sold some apparently very limited
apparel and but mostly we're coaching
lifters and then we recognized this
demographic that we
started attracting which was women but
but a lot of a lot of it was women who
had previous kind of poor experiences in
in the sport or with society or just
kind of in general their belonging was
like just kind of they felt a sense of
belonging as part of beef puffs having
coaches that they could relate to and
that could relate to them and so we
really took that and pushed it forward
just earlier this year my business
partner decided that she didn't want to
run a coaching company anymore and so it
worked out just fine because I wanted to
run a coaching company on my own and I
decided to take things in a slightly
different direction but you know similar
messaging so the Corvis strengths Co is
is the logo is a raven and Ravens are
very resilient and intelligent and
empathetic creatures and they also have
a special place in my heart I'm
originally from rural Alaska and so
Ravens are like we joke that they're the
state bird and they just are very
relevant in our world and so that's
where that came from an hour and it's
still power lifting coaching but with a
somewhat of a more emotional experience
to try to pursue some improved
resilience through strength training so
that's very similar to what we talked
about at beef buff barbell but just kind
of a different face in a different name
that that's that's really really cool
how's uh how's everything going like it
is that is that your full-time gig now I
remember okay I remember when last we
spoke you you're you're an engineer
right I have an engineering degree I
don't know that makes me an engineer it
does in my book yeah so it's not my
full-time gig and I I I wrestle with
this pretty often third there are times
I'm like right now where I try to you
know I would like to figure out a way to
make
a full-time gig but if I can't but then
you know I am afraid of putting myself
in a situation where I burn out from
both my competitive side of you know
being an athlete in the sport and a
coach in the sport and then what do I
have nothing so that's always been a
somewhat of a concern to me and I I try
to take a more realistic approach and I
so I do have a day job I'm I work in the
energy industry so renewable energy and
energy efficiency doing projects in
rural Alaska out of I work out of
Colorado but it's a nonprofit that I am
the executive director of but that's
that's super cool and what you're saying
makes a lot of sense as someone who does
still try to train and also like works
in string sports full-time like it's it
is it is a lot especially if you don't
have a ton of hobbies to fall back on
Mike you can love lifting all you want
but if it's it if you're forced to
literally think about it all the time
sometimes it can start feeling more like
more like work rather than kind of a
release and something you just enjoy
doing right which is what it is if
you're making your living off of it it
is work but it can take like a negative
kind of take a negative turn I suppose
yeah so when I asked you to come on one
of the things you said is that after
having been on Omar and Eric Helms
podcast that you still had a lot more
that she wanted to say on the topic of
the female experience and strength sport
generally mm-hmm so if I give you that
problem okay can you run with it or um
what would me a little bit more specific
kind of direction okay that's fair I'm
not a very good interviewer so I was
hoping I could get away with one there
sit back and listen what so what what
are like so obviously string sports can
be challenging for anyone but what are
some some
specific like challenges or social
pressures may be that women competing in
string sports may experience that either
men wouldn't or or don't to the same
degree okay sure
so I think the we can start with them
probably the most simple which is along
the lines of body image and and
aesthetic you know a appearance and
society societal pressures to appear a
certain way so if we kind of back it up
to the most basic the most basic
experience is when you know the kind of
general story that a guy learns that his
female friend or you know colleague is
taking up lifting or even CrossFit you
hear this in CrossFit all the time it's
it's don't get too bulky and that kind
of mentality while it might not that
might nowadays be a meme or like you
know just kind of a really basic example
and that we don't really hear of much
anymore it's still that message still
carries through to this day so I think
that that's a pretty significant
component that we shouldn't overlook in
general so for a lot of high-level
female athletes like it's not really a
problem they look like an athlete
they're smaller they're more kind of
bought into the sport and bought into
athletics in general but I think that it
still does play a role but I think it's
more in the realm of the kind of general
population of women who might have an
interest they might see someone popular
on Instagram powerlifting and they get
an interest in it but then they hear
from guys their significant other or
people even further from them than that
that they're gonna get big and buff and
I think that that's a problem which is
you know it's not a problem it shouldn't
be considered a problem so that's part
of it and then the other piece of it is
that a guy
wouldn't ever really experience that his
peers or a woman is never going to say
to him
yikes you shouldn't do that you're gonna
get too big you're gonna get your
muscles are gonna get too big so I think
that discrepancy between how women are
treated when they begin a strength
journey and men is is stark and pretty
alarming to me that it's it's still um
it's still a thing so I have you know
the majority I would say probably 80% of
client inquiries that I get are from
women who want to start powerlifting
they want to hire a coach they want to
get more serious about the sport but at
the same time they would like to drop a
weight class there they have you know
four in this hypothetical example
she's never competed before or maybe
she's done an unsanctioned meet you know
nothing like we're not even talking a
national qualifier we're talking
somebody who's who wants to be smaller
but also wants the benefits of feeling
empowered and strong and I think that's
really really interesting and concerning
that that's our initial you know you're
obviously interested enough in the sport
to want to hire a coach and pay top
dollar for programming and but at the
same time this arbitrary number of sixty
three kilos is what you want to weigh
even though that number is kind of
picked out of thin air by the people in
powerlifting and so yeah I think that's
a really interesting and problematic
kind of piece of the female experience
in the sport it absolutely kills me I
have had female clients in the past that
random people in their office will be
like oh make sure you don't lift you'll
get bulky random strangers people that
are not important in their life
whatsoever who think they have a valid
opinion on how they should treat their
own body is I just can't wrap my head
around it that's mine yeah it's insane
acquaintances that that are now at the
table trying to make decisions about how
much they should weigh and the thing
that kills me about it is
as as a male I you know I do natural
bodybuilding which means in four months
I don't know if I'm gonna weigh 200
pounds or 140 and those are real numbers
and I have never at any point in my life
at Greg knows it
I i fluctuate wildly and never in my
life has a significant other someone who
like the theoretically maybe would
deserve an opinion on that depending on
your viewpoint but even a significant
other has never told me like hey I wish
you wouldn't completely changed the way
your body looks and so to me the idea
that people think that they can go up to
a woman who's merely an acquaintance and
just levy an opinion on that is it is
something that that males just generally
don't have to deal with and I I don't
know where that comes from but I can't
imagine how frustrating that would be
yeah and and I've run into kind of the
consequences of that when coaching
lifters as well most of the time most of
the time unless someone is like quite
hefty on the front end if you've been
training for like a year or two you're
probably currently in a lower weight
class than you should end up in because
you know you can still build muscle and
you'll probably you'll probably be the
most competitive in the highest weight
class that you can get to with like
fairly decent body comp like that's
there there's you you can you can model
that or you can just kind of observe how
lifters tend to do and most of the men
I've coached have been super on board
with that and I would say 90% of the
women I've coached have either wanted to
gain muscle while staying in the same
weight class and lean out but for sure
stay in the same weight class or drop a
weight class and even when they asked me
like what's probably going to make me
most competitive in the long run when I
say well you know in my mind I'm
thinking probably need to move up about
to weight classes but I say like
probably need to move up a weight class
I get a ton of pushback
and then when I asked questions to kind
of like probe why that would be it's all
of the stuff you're talking about like
everyone in their life has told them
like oh if you lift you'll get bulky and
so now they're afraid that you know if I
if I get into the 72 class I'll be like
too bulky
yeah and they like internalize that and
that makes me very sad because like if
powerlifting is is the thing that they
say they want to focus on and they're
willing to pay a substantial amount of
money for coaching to improve like they
should they should be able to feel
comfortable like making the decisions
that they think will help them reach
their goals versus things that they not
even necessarily think will placate the
people in their lives but will just keep
them from getting [ __ ] from random
people in their lives yeah I think what
also in that kind of adds to the whole
issue is the chasing of arbitrary
numbers like I mentioned so it's like
these the 57 and 63 numbers like I'm not
opposed to coaching somebody to you know
how like being a powerlifting coach for
somebody who's trying to lose weight
like that's that's okay and I always
just make sure that we have the
priorities set straight so you know is
the goal weight loss or is the goal
strength you know gaining strengthen and
basically we kind of balance things with
with based on what the goals are but if
it's I want to get to 63 by November and
I also want to PR my total I'm like
that's insane like we just can't do that
that's not how this works do you do you
see any of those attitude shifting as
more women get into strength sports or
do you do you see them still remaining
just as recalc I see them just a
recalcitrant yeah sorry I do see them I
do see them shifting some I don't I
don't think that so let me back up I see
a general um there are more super
heavyweight or or 84 and then 84
plus-size like so I mean I'm just using
the IPF weight classes because that's
what I'm familiar with but basically
like a bigger bodied women are getting
interested in powerlifting more because
they're being exposed
to really high level athletes like
Bonica bonito Brown and Becky Becky
Holcomb so I think that we are so so I
don't know that it's generally like
changing internally within women or if
it's just we're getting more women who
are comfortable in bigger bodied women
who are comfortable with themselves kind
of changing the average but there is
there is a general shift and I I think
it's it's really cool because we're
getting a more diverse population
interested in the sport like it's not
it's not just about getting bigger women
into it's it's a it's showing showcasing
the smaller lifters like Heather Connor
that you know even though you weigh less
than a hundred pounds like you can still
be strong as [ __ ] and I think that's a
really important component too but I
think yeah I mean on on either on either
end we're seeing an increase because the
town you know we're just seeing a crazy
growth in the talent pool but the more
representation the better for the sport
what are what are some steps that people
listening to this could take to kind of
help shift attitudes and make and help
women feel more comfortable pursuing the
things they want to pursue and not
letting like other pressures force them
down a particular road yeah so the
obvious one is to stop making comments
about how women look so I just have this
interesting story that had the first
time that kind of stuck with me where
somebody some complete stranger in the
gym said something to me I was like I
had been in powerlifting for about a
year at the time I was in my early 20s
and I was just going up a weight class
so I started in the 72s and I went up to
the 84s after a little while and I had
put on like early on I just like put on
a lot of weight just muscle and fat you
know just kind of like generally got
bigger and that was fine
but I looked a lot stronger and I was
training at the gym I always trained at
every single day
I usually trained by myself or you know
with a group but was kind of doing my
own thing and some older guy walked up
to me and said wow you are a
thoroughbred like what that like that's
that's the worst attempt at a compliment
ever yeah it was it was insane and I
like as a you know - I was like 23 at
the time and I was just kind of like
like what
so I laughed at it I shouldn't I
understood that he was trying to
compliment me but I also was like what
in the world and this is a place where
I'm I'm training all the time I'm at
this gym all the time and I see the guy
like I see the guy there pretty
regularly kind of like so it just all of
a sudden made the whole environment like
a total different different feeling and
yeah that was my first kind of like
experience with something like that so I
think just generally speaking as far as
how people listening to this podcast can
can improve their or can help women
improve their kind of outlook on this is
think about if it would if you're a if
you're a man if like if I would
basically ask yourself would you say
this to your guy friend and if you
wouldn't simply say it to your friend
that's a male then don't say it to a
friend that's a female that's general
acquaintances kind of thing like I'm not
saying like significant others because
obviously that's a different deal but
from you know your the people you see in
the gym your training partner is like if
you wouldn't say the same thing and and
maybe that's maybe that's not the right
filter because guys can give each other
[ __ ] and stuff but I think that's a
decent place to start just because
you're you know as a as a guy is a just
person that trains with women you don't
have authority or in your opinion
doesn't really matter it shouldn't
matter to other people so though
it's kind of my main I would say my main
piece of advice is is really think about
one the message you're trying to get
across but also if it's not something
that you would say to guys you barely
know then why would you ever say it to a
woman that you barely know so is
complimenting a woman in saying that she
looks thick solid tight is that still on
the table because I say that to every
man in my life I've been on the
receiving end of that from people other
than great well Greg I mean if you're
gonna say it to your guy friends you
have to say to your female friends okay
for equality awesome pigs right sighs
keep us updated on your progress so we
can see how thick solid and tight you
can get ultimately I think the goal
should be to try to d-stick mitai x'
like i want us to be able to kind of
communicate within the sport and within
like the range of what's appropriate
comfortably so it would be amazing if we
got to a day where you could communicate
with your like female clients in the
same way that you or your female friends
in the same way that you communicate
with your male friends without having to
put like like really think about it but
I think we're at this point where it's
too much of a stigmatized issue like
you're going to probably offend somebody
but it would be great if we all got to a
point where we're also comfortable and
proud of our bodies and our what our
bodies are capable of that we could just
like you know freely talk about things
like that
say like you Wow you're looking jacked
or you're looking huge without it being
like a potential trigger or offensive
comment no that that makes sense so one
thing that's kind of related to what
we've talked about already you know when
we were preparing for the interview I
looked into your competition history and
I saw that you did make a change in
weight class I think around like 2014
and I think on the coaching side of
things Greg I'm sure I mean I'm sure all
of us have heard this but
you get someone in who's maybe on the
verge of maybe bumping up and I see so
many lifters early in their career that
are so hesitant to bump up a weight
class so what's kind of like your main
what is that decision-making process
when it comes to whether or not somebody
should bump up or try to hang on to
their weight class that they're at um
yeah I think that it it obviously
depends on several factors in the
situation but generally speaking I like
to get a good sense of what an athlete's
nutrition looks like on a you know not
just during the last 12 weeks before a
competition but year-round like are you
eating like an [ __ ] for eight months
of the year and can we dial that in and
then potentially keep you closer to your
weight class and then just you know make
the water cut or the the small diet
small deficit easier that's I mean I
would say that the thought process
around it is probably pretty similar to
when you have a male athlete in the same
situation however you have to manage the
the the emotional and mental side of
things may be a little bit more than
than with most guys so I generally
approach it with let's just go into this
meat without a cut so you might only be
three kilos or four kilos over and but
we'll go in in a caloric surplus without
a water cut and then you let the lifting
and the PR is kind of speak for you I
think more often than not if somebody
has been cutting pretty hard or dieting
and then cutting they're going to and
and then they're you know getting to a
point where their total is not going up
as you know as at the rate that they
would like to see and their training is
not as fun and they're kind of
restricted most a lot of the year or
several weeks more weeks and you know
more months and they want to be
restricted I think you I think it's most
important to kind of let that decision
happen on the athlete side and one way
you can do that like I said is by just
eliminating the deficit and the week
and let the big huge PR total speak for
itself we don't have to jump full into
you know you don't need to fill out the
next weight class right away and and
that's another kind of important message
that needs to be relayed like you can be
midway through you can be 67 kilos and
that gives you you know one room to grow
slowly into the 72 s but also maybe some
peace of mind that you're not going to
just like all of a sudden put on you
know an additional five kilos of body
fat yeah that's a great way of looking
at it I remember the only time I was in
that position I was like right between
two weight classes and I was so focused
on a particular number I wanted to hit
that I was like well why would I risk
missing that just to bump down a weight
class but I guess that really would help
kind of shift the focus on like let's
just look at the numbers we're going for
set some PRS and I mean once your
training starts going so smoothly at
that higher weight than then you'd be a
lot more open to the idea of like yeah
let's just stay here yeah and then and
then over time slowly fill that out I
think I do right yeah yeah I mean I also
think that way too many lifters are
focused way to much on weight classes in
the first place like if for a lot of
people like winning a state championship
or qualifying for Nationals like that
maybe the biggest thing they ever
accomplished in the sport and if you're
kind of at that level and it's like okay
like there's there's some like big
things that that matter a lot to me that
like I really want to accomplish then
it's like okay let's start thinking
about what weight class would be best
for me to do it in like what qualifying
total looks manageable what weight class
in my state do I think I could probably
like you know pick off a win in I think
that's that's very reasonable but like
that's not going to be at least like
two-thirds three-quarters of lifters out
there and I think I think until you kind
of get to that level that you're
approaching like very serious
competitive goals you should just kind
of train and lift and roll up to a meet
at whatever weights you want to be at
and then you know once you start
reaching that point that it's like okay
there's there's some some big things I
have my eye on then start thinking about
weight classes but until that point just
just get strong and that will often
coincide with with gaining some weight
in the process as long as your body comp
doesn't get way too out of control yeah
I completely agree Natalie is there is
there anything else you would like to to
leave the audience with that we haven't
covered yet did we get to whatever you
missed out on when you were on Helms and
Omar's podcast yeah I mean I think that
it wasn't necessarily any like
particular points that I wanted to make
but it was just kind of like this
conversation that could have kept going
and going I I think that a lot of those
topics will be addressed by having
female elite athletes and coaches on
podcast some kind of more often we we
just don't really don't really get on
podcasts very often and so you know
there's there are some folks that have
some women that have some really
interesting insight from like we had we
talked with Jenn Thompson and she's been
in the sport a lot longer than Stephie
and I and she just has some interesting
perspective that you know but I don't
have and that you know a lot of people
don't have so that's really where I was
kind of going with that that makes sense
in chin is a [ __ ] mods yeah she's
amazing people don't understand how good
at bench pressing she truly is like so
this this is just kind of an aside but a
while back I downloaded all of the data
from Open powerlifting and I was trying
to this was before the IPF formula came
out and I was trying to like play around
with it and come up with a scalene
formula that worked better than Wilkes
but that didn't piss people off as much
as allometric scaling did and one of the
things that I kind of wanted to see is
you know in these formulas I'm playing
around with how how far
mean in terms of like standard
deviations are these various like very
very good lifters and Jen Thompson's
bench press was like eight point six
standard deviations from the mean for
like scaled bench press for for all
drug-free female competitors and then
even if I isolated it to just like the
top ten percentile so you know people
who might not necessarily be world-class
but who are quite good lifters she was
still like almost five standard
deviations from the mean above them and
just for context like not his not his
most recent total but the the prior
record that John hack had add in the
eighty three kilo class for men which
was probably the best total anyone had
hit in the IPF since maybe one of Jesse
Morris's big totals he was like his
total was like four point six standard
deviations from from the mean not like
the mean of the top ten percent of
lifters but just the mean which like
almost five standard deviations is still
wild but like gins bench was as far
above the the just top ten percent of
lifters versus it was like her bench was
comparable e above the top ten percent
that John's total was above like the the
average and John's also ridiculously
yeah so basically Jen is a [ __ ]
monster and Greg you know that I love
statistics just so the listeners
appreciate what like as a researcher if
I have a data point that's three
standard deviations from the mean almost
always I can just in the paper report
like that that number was so abnormal
that I chose to disregard it like three
standard deviations is kind of the
research standard at which point you
would say I can throw that out because
that's just insane if it's four standard
deviations away no one would ever fight
you on the decision of like well I need
to exclude that from the analysis
because it's just simply insane nine
standard Eevee
that is crazy yeah the the criterion
used for like aircraft engineering to
make sure that the materials have like
high enough tolerances that like a wing
doesn't fall off when you're when you're
flying they use I believe the 7 Sigma
standard which is basically like these
materials their strength is 7 standard
deviations higher than would be required
for like typical flight conditions and
like that that's considered an
incredibly like unbelievably safe
standard for engineering things that you
want to really make sure don't fall out
of the sky and Jen's like another two
standard deviations beyond that so just
like Jen is amazing but I I would like
to point out that there is a that she
was in a very close battle with a
Russian at bench worlds who was nearly
as strong as she is and then there's an
Italian girl her name's Carla Guerra who
benches who's benched 133 kilos at 63
just recently so oh we're talking I mean
it's what is you know this is Jen is
setting the standard like we were saying
earlier she's setting this the standard
at you know 145 kilos or whatever it is
and now women are where the talent pool
is opening up so much that we have women
63-kilo women who are chasing that that
number and getting close to it we're
gonna have to recalculate those
deviations so that being the case so so
obviously like I believe all of our
assumptions is or probably that the
sports going to keep growing keep
improving the records are gonna keep
going up where where do you personally
see women's power lifting heading in the
next like five years or so like some of
like the outlier people that we look at
right now so like look at Jen Thompson
and how crazy her bench press is do you
think that that's kind of just going to
be the standard of like well if you're
not kind of close to this you're not
really going to be competitive in any
class five years from now or do you
think that it's going to be like a
little bit less of a explosion than that
well I have thoughts on this so if we
can open it up a little bit more
generally I am very curious to see how
what turnover in the sport begins to
look like over the next few years so
this isn't specific to female
powerlifting at all but I just have this
like curiosity in so a lot of the top
equipped power lifters that we see have
been doing this have been in the sport
for you know 15 10 15 20 years and when
raw became more popular and became like
a recognised division a lot of the kind
of old-timer coaches said well you know
gear is what kept people healthy and
kept people lifting for longer and
that's why you have people like
Priscilla Rubik who continued to win 20
years into the game and you know she
just her longevity was improved by the
equipment she was using and you know I
always took that with a grain of salt
because I think that a lot of people
were somewhat resistant to raw becoming
more popular however fast forward to
2019 I think that we're seeing really
seems to me like a really high rate of
either of injury that puts people out of
the sport almost indefinitely and I just
am very curious to see if going forward
you know the next decade or 15 years if
we started to see people who show up do
some crazy [ __ ] hit break records and
then they don't but they don't last more
than five years because they're they
just push it so hard so fast and then
kind of fall apart
and so you know I think that the let's
that's more of generally in the sport
and I'm I'm gonna be very curious to see
how that all kind of how that how the
chips fall in that way I think back to
your question about women in the sport
and and female powerlifting as a as a
division yeah I think that we're seeing
I think we're just scratching the
surface of what we're going to start
seeing like as far as performances go
and I you know it's there
there are women hitting numbers that are
mind-blowing to you know I'm I'm 84
kilos there are 63 kilo women hitting
close to my best ever total and and I
when when I last Rami I broke the
American record total in the 84th and so
it's like 100 kilos more than that is
the American record and that was just in
2016 so that's the gives you an idea of
the trajectory we're we're talking about
here
it was 505 at the Arnold in 2016 and now
the American record total is 603 I
believe in that same weight class yes
yeah so with that in mind yeah I think
that we're gonna keep seeing this to
some degree I don't think it's gonna
continue at the same trajectory forever
obviously like that just isn't how it
works but I think that we will see
things are just gonna continue to
ratchet up and but I but I want to know
I I'll be you know like I said I'll be
interested to see how how long people in
general stick with it or do they just
show up do some crazy [ __ ] and then you
know their back is no longer in
condition to hit those same high totals
and so they like burnout because they're
not as strong as they were a year ago
and you know just kind of how that all
works out do you do you think that
turnover is lower in multiply like you
mentioned a couple who earn a monkey for
advice and multiply lifting advice and
I'm like don't know what to tell you
yeah yeah cuz like you you you mention
a few people who have had exceptional
longevity but do you do I mean obviously
that's not typical but in terms of like
the average lifter have you seen people
with more longevity and lower turnover
with single ply I think so I think that
there's more I think that there are more
lifters who are competing now and at
least on the international level I you
know the national level is a little bit
of a different because we're for the
most part like people are managing their
their careers and their children and and
we're like it's a hobby so you're gonna
see more turnover because of that just
naturally but when we're talking about
the international scale where there are
state sponsored programs and people are
powered you know a sportsman as their
IPF profile will say there are
professional sportsmen we are we have
there's a lot of people who have been
lifting for a long time I you know we
could name names but it's it's pretty
remarkable how many like masters 1
lifters are breaking the world record
total that kind of thing that makes
sense it'll it'll be interesting to see
how things swing like especially since
we're always getting a lot of the
attention now if if a lot of the people
who the spotlight is on in the sport
currently if a lot of them made the
shift to single-ply yeah I think it
would be interesting to see what would
happen on the single-ply side of things
if it experienced like the same
explosion in interest there all has in
recent years oh yeah I don't really see
that happening I don't think it's that
appealing but I mean it would be very
interesting but I just I don't it's a
different animal it's not at all it's
not flashy fair enough so we've reached
the magical point in this interview
where you have as much time as you want
to show anything you could possibly want
to show so where can where can people
find you what sort of products and
services are you putting out onto the
marketplace let us have it cool
no pressure but this this part of the
show is basically the lifeblood of
capitalism has a concept so make sure
you live up to that standard so I am a
powerlifting coach with Corvis strength
Co and the website is WWII and any
information that you would like to know
about our services there and then I'm on
instagram at natalie dot 9:07 and yeah
that's about it
it was alright it's fine yeah I I think
capitalism has been weakened somewhat
but will will live to see another day
yeah well thank you thank you so much
for coming on it's been awesome thank
you yeah thank you very much for joining
us thanks for listening to the stronger
by science podcast now Greg and I are
not experts in medicine or health or
really anything else for that matter so
before you make any changes to your diet
and exercise habits make sure you check
with a doctor or another health care
professional if you enjoyed this podcast
and you'd like to support it visit
stronger by science com to check out the
products and services that we offer
thanks for listening and we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you